la valoración o titulación es un método
de análisis que se utiliza para
determinar la concentración de una
solución supongamos que empezamos con
una solución ácida como por ejemplo
ácido clorhídrico aquí tenemos un poco
de hcl y empezamos con 20 mililitros de
hcl pero no sabemos cuál es la
concentración entonces nosotros podemos
encontrar esa concentración por medio de
una titulación así que agregamos unas
gotas de indicador ácido base usaremos
fenol tal en la fe nolf talina es
incolora en un ambiente ácido pero en
presencia de una base se vuelve de color
rosa como en este caso agregamos fenol
talina a una solución ácida tenemos una
solución transparente
aquí arriba tenemos nuestra solución
estándar es una solución de
concentración conocida de hidróxido de
sodio entonces tenemos una solución de
hidróxido de sodio y su concentración es
0.1 00 molar ya estamos listos para
iniciar la titulación si dejamos caer
unas gotas de hidróxido de sodio en el
matraz que contiene la solución de hcl
provocando que el ácido y la base
reaccionen se da una reacción de
neutralización hcl más n
h producen si juntamos o h - y h +
obtenemos h2o y el otro producto se
forma con enea + y cl - n hace él
y cloruro de sodio
supongamos que ya agregamos un cierto
volumen de nuestra base por lo tanto
tenemos más líquido en el matraz y
observamos que la solución es de color
rosa eso significa que el ácido ha sido
neutralizado por la base y tenemos un
pequeño exceso de la base provocando que
el indicador ha sido base permanezca de
color rosa entonces neutralizamos al
ácido presente y al momento en que el
indicador cambia de color se le conoce
como el punto final de la titulación
cuando la solución cambia de color nos
encontramos en el punto final de la
titulación justo ahí es en donde nos
detenemos y checamos cuánto volumen de
la base agregamos por ejemplo supongamos
que empezamos aquí y terminamos acá aún
nos queda un poco de solución básica
entonces es
es el volumen de la base que usamos en
la titulación hay un cambio de volumen y
supongamos que esté 48.6 mililitros
usamos 48.6 mililitros de la base para
neutralizar completamente el ácido en la
solución ya que conocemos esto podemos
calcular la concentración de hcl
empecemos con la concentración de
hidróxido de sodio empezamos con una
concentración 0.1 00 molar de hidróxido
de sodio 0.1 00 molar recordemos que la
modalidad es igual a los moles sobre los
litros esto es igual a moles sobre
litros y nuestro objetivo es calcular
cuántos moles de la base usamos para
neutralizar el ácido que estaba presente
así que tomemos el volumen de 48.6
mililitros
y vamos a convertirlo a litros solo
movemos el punto decimal tres lugares a
la izquierda 1-2-3 tenemos cero puntos 0
486 litros entonces esto es igual a
moles entre 0.0 486 litros
voy a reescribir lo aquí abajo 0.1 0 0
es igual a equis entre 0.0 486 x
representan los moles de hidróxido de
sodio que se necesitaron para
neutralizar al ácido entonces si
calculamos el valor de x x es igual a
0.00 486 moles de hidróxido de sodio
ahora echemos un vistazo a nuestra
reacción balanceada
aquí tenemos uno como coeficiente
y aquí tenemos otro uno así que tenemos
una relación uno a uno molar ahora el
punto de equivalencia es cuando la
cantidad suficiente de la solución
estándar ha sido agregada para
reaccionar completamente con la solución
que ha sido titulada es decir en el
punto de equivalencia todo el ácido ha
sido neutralizado y como tenemos una
relación uno a uno molar podemos usar
estos moles de hidróxido de sodio para
saber cuántos moles de hcl teníamos
presentes en la solución entonces
podemos decir que teníamos 0.00 486
moles de hcl en el matraz antes de
iniciar la titulación porque tenemos una
relación 11 molar recuerden que nuestro
objetivo es encontrar la concentración
original de hcl y como la concentración
molar es
a los moles sobre litros si ya conocemos
los moles de hcl y sabemos que el
volumen inicial era de 20 mililitros
vamos a convertirlos a litros movemos el
punto decimal 1 2 3 veces tenemos 0.02
litros entonces el paso final es
calcular la concentración de hcl la
concentración es igual a los moles de
hcl 0.00 486 moles entre los litros de
la solución inicial que es igual a 0.0
200 litros usemos la calculadora tenemos
0.00 486 entre 0.0 200 esto es igual a
cero punto 243
en tracción de hcl es igual a cero punto
243 molar esta es la concentración de la
solución inicial de hcl ahora existe un
pequeño atajo que podemos usar para este
problema concentración molar por el
volumen del ácido es igual a la
concentración molar por el volumen usado
de la base mv es igual a emv del lado
izquierdo
tenemos el ácido y del lado derecho
tenemos la base entonces si queremos
saber la concentración molar del ácido
que sería nuestra x por el volumen
inicial del ácido que lo podemos dejar
en mililitros 20.0 mililitros es igual a
la concentración de la base que usamos
para la titulación que fue de 0.1 00
molar por el volumen de la base que
usamos para neutralizar completamente al
ácido que fue de 48.6 mililitros
observen que los mililitros se cancelan
y podemos simplemente calcular x usemos
nuevamente la calculadora tenemos 48.6
por 0.1 00 entre 20 es igual a cero
punto 243 x es igual a cero puntos 243
molar este atajo funciona muy bien
cuando tenemos un ácido fuerte y una
base fuerte en una relación uno a uno
molar en el siguiente vídeo haremos un
problema en donde la relación molar no
es 1 a 1